okay the Crusades are back in the news
to which I must
opine Peter Heth Donald Trump's pick for
the to lead the incoming Department of
Defense is apparently a crusader Fanboy
that's an actual quote um from one of
the media attacks on him he likes the
Crusades he speaks well about the
Crusades he has Crusader type tattoos
including the Crusader cross as well as
the Latin phrase deusvult which means
means god wills it and we'll get to that
in a moment but because of all that he
is under attack by the media and that's
important for three specific reasons the
first has to do with what I call fake
history fake history just like fake news
is all about poisoning your
understanding about current events etc
etc but in a way it's um possibly even
worse and has far reaching consequences
as compared to its more temporal
corollary fake news
fake history creates an overarching
narrative that's false a false first
premise and then everything that happens
thereafter including current events such
as what we'll get into becomes poisoned
because of the first premise the history
is fake so the New York Times for
example um that's probably one of the
biggest places that wrote a hip piece on
him published an oped called um Peter
Heth and his battlecry for a new
Christian Crusade and the entire piece
of course doesn't Define what the
Crusades were about except in a negative
sense offers all these negative
connotations they were full of
atrocities you get the idea that Muslims
were peaceful and just these evil
Crusaders decided to come overseas and
attack and colonize etc etc and they
don't have to do a lot of homework and
they don't even have to say that because
that is the prevalent interpretation
nowadays of the Crusades so among other
things the New York Times defines the
Crusades as quote campaigns that
featured so many atrocities
and quote a shameful stain on the region
or religion's history all
right
so I've already talked about the
Crusades a lot uh basically they are
among the most warranted Wars of History
because right before the Crusades
Muslims were completely annihilating and
destroying and committing all sorts of
atrocities against
Christians uh we forget that the First
Crusade came four centuries after after
Muslims had conquered through violence
through the sword about 34s of formerly
Christian territory which is North
Africa in the Middle East and also Spain
was conquered at that time and later the
Eastern Eastern Europe and the Balkans
etc etc but right before the Crusades
not only had a huge chunk of former
Christendom been conquered but uh it was
one of the most violent manifestations
at that time I speak of the selic Turks
who were running a Muk in Asia Minor
Anatolia today turkey but also in the
Holy Land committing non-stop atrocities
that are mind-boggling I have them in my
book if you're interested sword and
Scimitar uh it's all documented and
right there but that's what provoked
Pope Urban II in 1095 at the Council of
Clermont to call for the First Crusade
and he described what was happening to
Eastern Christians and the atrocities
and churches being destroyed literally
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
Christians were either slaughtered from
between 1071 and 1095 when the First
Crusade was called and thousands of
churches burned ransacked and or turned
into mosques okay so that's what
prompted the First Crusade but because
that's not known um and everyone's been
taught that the Crusades are these evil
unwarranted you know white patriarchical
sort of Ventures they can get away with
demonizing a fellow like Heth just
because he likes the Crusades and he has
these Crusader tattoos so that's the
first point because of the fake history
that dominates concerning the
Crusades someone who just likes the
Crusades because they're actually they
were Noble and just by and large at
least their motivation can now be
demonized someone like Heth and uh
obviously a lot of people which leads to
the second point but all the Articles
and op-eds and hit pieces I saw that
emanated including the New York Times
try to connect those who like the
Crusades such as Heth as being white
supremacist so that's proof positive
that you are a white supremacist you
have a crusader tattoo or or you've
spoken well about the
Crusades well that overlooks the reality
of why that is certainly it's true
Crusaders were white Europeans and their
enemies were brownish Muslims right but
beyond that fact which people obsess
over is why that was the case because
when as I was speaking about the
conquest of the larger part of
Christendom in the 7th Century all of
North Africa in the Middle East which
was Christian got conquered so the
peoples who were not European from Egypt
and Syria and Morocco and North Africa
which was the older Christian region
those people were conquered subdued many
converted to Islam many lived as zies
but they couldn't fight back so the
reason that it was white peoples
Europeans who actually fought the
Muslims is because they were all that
was left Europe was the final Bastion of
Christendom and even parts of it as I
mentioned had already been conquered
Spain and occupied for many centuries
for example so the reality is yes it's
true there was a dichotomy a racial one
if you like um with the Crusaders being
overwhelmingly white European Etc and
their enemies being the opposite but
that has nothing to do with the the race
itself that's not why they attacked them
it's the point is when they say so and
so is a white suprem premist cuz he
likes the Crusades they're trying to
they're trying to man manipulate this
fact into making you think that the
Crusaders were racist that's why they
went and attacked these Brown peaceful
Muslims in other words the reason that
it was whites and Europeans who led the
Crusades has nothing to do with the race
but rather all that was left of free
Christendom was peopled by
whites but of course nowadays none of
that matters the history I just
mentioned the conquest of North Africa
in the Middle East and the fact that all
that was left were the peoples of Europe
doesn't matter all that is seen today
via the identity politics lens is the
colors of both participants so you have
whites fighting non-whites and based on
the predominant formula that means that
the former the whites are the bad guys
and the latter the Muslims the
non-whites are the innocent
victims in reality this is just another
way name call calling white supremacism
to make people Veer away from liking or
being appreciative of the Crusades but
like I said the Crusades were amongst
the most just Wars of all time and
people who are inclined to Justice May
favor them and like them and be and
supportive of them such as I assume Heth
but now they're all dismissed as white
supremacists and under this logic I your
friendly neighborhood Mr ibraim am also
a white
supremacist the final Point probably the
most subtle is that in all the pieces
that I read the New York Times and so
forth and I've seen this a lot whenever
you get someone who understands the
Crusades correctly the way we're
discussing it and maybe even holds a
favorable view of the Crusades they
always have this sort of yes but
approach yeah the Crusades were
important but yeah there were terrible
atrocities etc etc in fact I think in
one of the uh articles in New York Times
maybe they quoted hex to that effect
where he yeah he likes the Crusades but
he went out of his way to tell you no of
course they had Mega atrocities etc etc
and so did a lot of other uh Scholars
and historians good ones also quoted in
these pieces hex for example is quoted I
believe the New York Times as saying
even though the Crusades were important
they still were full of injustices quote
I'm quoting him now quote Injustice is
an unspeakable tragedy all right okay so
the problem with this position which is
spoken by hex and other people many
other people who support and believe the
Crusades was a good thing is that it
raises an important question what war
was not full of atrocities and
unspeakable tragedies every single war
that I know of is inundated with
injustices and unspeakable tragedies the
and the Crusades went on for well over
two centuries at least in the holy land
and longer elsewhere um so one would
expect there would be some injustice and
unspeakable tragedies and yet we don't
say that we don't begin discussions of
other Wars by noting that every single
War you can think of the most
romanticized wars of patriotic lore
including the American Revolution World
War I Civil War and you will find tons
of atrocities committed by the good guys
you know but who now for example speaks
and says that World War II America's
role in World War II was problematic
because don't you know American GIS
raped about 15,000 women in England and
France and Germany right we don't do
that people do people introduce
America's role in World War II as
questionable something that we really
have to do a lot of Heming and hming
about and ringing our hands about
because of this unfortunate fact the
rape of 15,000 women they don't and they
don't do it about any other Wars so why
is it always and only for the Crusades
that we have to ring our hands and
apologize and offer all these caveats
and equivocate about the meaning of the
Crusades it was like those other Wars
yeah bad things happened but I would
argue a lot better things happened at
least the motivation behind it was
nobler and just as opposed to so many
modern Wars that are not introduced in
this way as these bad horrible things
that we must always keep in our mind so
my my position is not that bad things
didn't happen but rather let's be
consistent uh either from now on when
you speak about any War you have to ring
your hands and talk about how horrible
the atrocities were just like with the
Crusades or else don't single them out
to some sort of special standard that no
one has ever met anyway there it is my
two cents or rather my three points on
the recent attack on the concept of the
crusade in the context of Pete Heth all
right bye